ahora que ya sabemos cómo construir un
vector normal unitario en cualquier
punto de una curva y qué era lo que
habíamos estado haciendo en el vídeo
anterior
quiero empezar a explorar expresiones
interesantes y la expresión que quiero
revisar es la integral la integral sobre
una curva cerrada que le voy a llamar se
de efe de un campo vectorial
efe punto el vector normal unitario el
vector normal unitario que voy a
llamarle n con este gordito chistoso por
un pequeño cambio en la longitud de arco
ok entonces déjenme hacer algunos
dibujos respecto de esto vamos a pintar
primero los ejes
y ahí tenemos el eje y y el eje x vamos
a pintarlo por aquí
y ahí tenemos el eje x y voy a pintar
una curva una curva cerrada simple
bonita de esta forma ok
esta es nuestra curva se y que de hecho
tiene una orientación y una orientación
positiva es decir que vamos en el
sentido contrario a las manecillas del
reloj y aquí tengo pues mi cambio mi
campo vectorial
efe que en realidad está definido en
todo mi espacio de r2 por ejemplo
también acá pero nos vamos a concentrar
esencialmente en qué pasa con él con el
campo vectorial sobre la curva y digamos
que si el campo vectorial es efe de x
que es un campo vectorial pues tiene dos
componentes porque lo estamos definiendo
en r2 digamos que en una componente es p
de xy en nuestra primera componente en
la dirección
i
q de xy en la dirección j es decir en la
dirección vertical y estas dos funciones
son funciones que dependen de xy de ye y
que me construye en mi campo vectorial y
nos interesa ver qué pasa sobre la curva
verdad si por ejemplo aquí tenemos este
en este punto que el campo vectorial
apunta en esta dirección también vamos a
considerar nuestro vector normal
unitario nuestro vector normal unitario
que es justamente ortogonal a la curva
correcto entonces déjenme déjenme
extender un poco más este vector
vamos a corregirlo un poquito
vamos a extenderlo un poquito más para
que quede más clara la idea que quiero
presentarles muy bien ahí está ahora ya
que está hecho esto en realidad queremos
calcular
efe punto n ok vamos a tratar de
trabajar toda esta integral
desarrollando un poquito la idea de qué
es lo que nos está diciendo esto y
después vamos a usar el teorema de green
y llegar al al famoso y conocidísimo
teorema de la divergencia pero para eso
necesitamos primero ver qué es lo que
ocurre con este producto punto d efe
punto n si aquí tengo yo mi campo
vectorial y aquí tengo el vector normal
unitario n este es el vector normal
unitario en ese punto
en realidad el producto punto de estos
dos me está diciendo que tanto hay que
extender n que tanto hay que extender n
para que sea la componente
correspondiente a este vector es decir
estaría yo extendiendo
todo esto y sería la magnitud de este
vector para para ir formando este vector
normal unitario es decir es como hasta
cierto punto una proyección verdad
entonces esto
este producto lo que me está diciendo lo
que me está midiendo es la magnitud la
magnitud de
de la componente de la componente
componente en el campo vectorial
efe en la dirección normal es decir en
la dirección del vector normal unitario
de la dirección normal ok y vamos a ver
como como podríamos interpretar todo
esto supongamos por ejemplo que todo
esto que estamos viendo estamos viviendo
en un mundo de dos dimensiones y que
aquí tenemos digamos algún gas ok
tenemos algún gas en este en este
pequeño mundo de dos dimensiones y estas
flechas lo que es el campo vectorial me
está indicando cuál es la velocidad que
lleva el gas en cada uno de los puntos
por ejemplo a lo mejor el gas se mueve
de esta forma en este punto este lleva
mucha velocidad en este punto qué sé yo
ok entonces este campo vectorial me está
diciendo la velocidad que lleva el gas
en cada uno de los puntos en particular
me interesa saber la velocidad del gas
sobre la frontera o el contorno de esta
región ok por qué porque si yo hago el
producto punto de lo que es la velocidad
que es el campo vectorial y con este
vector normal unitario en realidad aquí
estamos midiendo que a qué velocidad o
más bien a qué rapidez es a la que
escapa a esa la que escapa el gas y
cuando digo escapa digo podría estar
entrando o saliendo pero pero estamos
considerando el vector normal exterior
verdad entonces eso me está midiendo qué
tanto sale si es negativo pues en
realidad está entrando verdad pero
estamos considerando esta referencia y
entonces esta magnitud
efe punto n lo que me está diciendo es
la rapidez a la cual escapa el gas en
este punto en particular ahora que sí
estamos multiplicando por de s es decir
por un pequeño cambio en la longitud de
arco
aquí me está y además estamos después
sumando sobre toda la curva estamos
viendo qué
rápido escapa el gas sobre toda la curva
verdad que tanto que tanto material de
gas está escapando por toda la curva ok
esto es un argumento un poquito
complicado y medio
digamos hecho en pocas palabras vamos a
detallar en esto un poquito más adelante
o quizás en otro vídeo ahorita lo que
quiero centrarme es realmente a
manipular esta expresión de aquí que
dijimos que si lo estamos interpretando
en términos de gases esto es que tan
rápido
estoy aquí es que tan rápido
rápido escapa escapa del gas o escapan
las partículas de gas digamos las
partículas por la por la frontera o por
el contorno por la frontera ok entonces
vamos a seguir manipulando esta
expresión y podemos manipularla porque
acá arriba tenemos una forma de expresar
el vector normal unitario entonces eso
lo podemos sustituir inmediatamente de
esta integral entonces realmente tenemos
la integral sobre una curva se orientada
de esta forma de nuestro campo vectorial
efe punto el vector normal unitario que
como habíamos dicho es
de y el cambio pequeño cambio en la
dirección y por el vector y menos de x
sobre por la dirección j y vamos a
dividir vamos a dividir todo esto entre
de s verdad pero aquí estamos
multiplicando también por de s que de
hecho son digamos magnitudes escalares
esto es un escalar entonces esta
división del df con esta multiplicación
que tengo aquí por la integral en
realidad se cancela porque son escalares
y lo único que me queda es f punto este
vector que es de y en la dirección y
menos de x en la dirección j entonces lo
único que me queda es calcular la
integral
la integral sobre esta curva se de efe
que es p
qué es una función que depende de xy de
y que va en la dirección y más q que es
otra función que depende de x y que va
en la dirección j entonces si hacemos
este producto con de este vector que es
el campo vectorial con este vector azul
lo que nos queda es p y por d ye y
verdad
estamos pensando en los vectores en este
producto es decir todo esto vamos a
hacerlo más específicamente vamos a
hacer pe y más cool j punto punto esta
parte azul que es de g y menos de equis
j
y hay que recordar que iu y j son
ortogonales entonces cuando hagamos los
productos cruzados se van a anular
verdad entonces esto simplemente me
queda para por belle y sería
pd y pdl y me falta hacer el producto
punto y punto y pero como este es un
vector normal con perdón un vector que
tiene norma 1 simplemente nos queda y
punto y que es la norma de y al cuadrado
que es una verdad y luego tenemos
punto de x j pero y j son ortogonales
por lo tanto eso se anula lo mismo pasa
cuando yo hago q j.de y como son
ortogonales se cancelan y simplemente me
queda hacer con jota punto menos de x j
entonces esto nos quedaría esto es igual
a pdl menos q de x y jota punto jota es
igual a 1 verdad porque jota tiene norma
1 muy bien entonces esta es la expresión
que nos queda p de x y por belle menos q
de x
de x y esto vamos a tener que recordar
muy bien que es lo que nos dice el
teorema de greene porque si recuerdas
esto es muy parecido a lo que podría
especificar nos el teorema de green y
realmente el teorema de green lo que nos
dice es que si tenemos la integral sobre
una curvas
m de x déjenme ponerlo en amarillo para
que sea más acorde a lo que llevamos mx
nd y si ésta es la integral del link de
línea esto por el teorema de green lo
podemos pasar a una integral sobre una
región la integral doble sobre la región
que que acota nuestra nuestra curva se
de la parcial de n de esta parte la
parcial de n respecto de x menos la
parcial de m respecto de ella y todo
esto hay que multiplicarlo por una
pequeña diferencial de área que puede
ser de x de the x según sea el caso
verdad entonces esto es lo que nos dice
el teorema de greene esto es el teorema
de greene
de green y hay que esto lo podemos
aplicar en esta expresión que tenemos
verdad porque esto según el teorema de
green nos lo lleva a una integral sobre
una región r donde hay que sacar primero
la parcial de esta función que está
multiplicando a de ella que en este caso
es p entonces vamos a tener la parcial
de p respecto de x respecto de x y hay
que poner menos y ahora tenemos que
sacar la parcial de la otra función que
multiplica a de x que en este caso es
menos q entonces vamos a tener menos la
parcial de q respecto de y y todo esto
va a ser multiplicado por una pequeña
diferencial de área verdad y esto si
seguimos manipulando lo es igual a la
integral sobre la región r de la parcial
de p respecto de x
más porque es menos y menos esto es más
la parcial de q respecto de y ok y todo
esto por una diferencial de área y
quizás ya estás viendo hacia dónde vamos
porque a lo mejor ya es ya ya tienes esa
intuición desarrollada para ver qué es
esto porque si no si no recuerdas vamos
a revisar que esto no es otra cosa más
que la divergencia de nuestro campo
vectorial verdad es la suma de las
derivadas parciales en este en este
orden esta es la divergencia de nuestro
campo vectorial si para ti no tiene
sentido que es la divergencia y te
recomiendo que cheques el vídeo que
trata sobre la divergencia de los campos
vectoriales entonces esto ya para
concluir es la integral sobre la región
r sobre la región r del de la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial
efe multiplicado por una pequeña
diferencial de área entonces aquí lo que
tuvimos es una integral de 1
de alguna curva que al desarrollar este
producto punto llegamos a una expresión
en donde podíamos utilizar el teorema de
green y con el teorema de green llegamos
a esto que es esencialmente el teorema
de la divergencia ahora porque tiene
sentido esto bueno recordemos la
interpretación de lo que es la
divergencia es decir la divergencia nos
va midiendo que tanto salen las cosas a
partir de un punto por ejemplo si
tenemos que el campo vectorial es más o
menos de esta forma aquí cerca entonces
la divergencia es positiva sin embargo
si si tenemos que es más o menos de esta
forma es decir donde digamos que el
campo vectorial va apuntando hacia
dentro de alguna región entonces la
divergencia es negativa es decir aquí
podríamos pensar que hay común con una
especie de punto atractor verdad que
concentra la las partículas de este gas
entonces todo esto todo espero que tenga
o que haya cobrado sentido es una forma
de pensar en el teorema de greene para
también
y explorarlo y llegar a la conclusión de
lo que nos dice el teorema de la
divergencia en dos dimensiones verdad
que en realidad estamos sumando la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial a
lo largo de toda esta región